la decisión del tribunal supremo de eeuu
una multitud se reunió en parís para
expresar su preocupación da mucho miedo
imaginar cómo podría influir en el resto
del mundo el extremismo ha ido en
aumento en francia por lo que es
preocupante que este derecho pueda
cuestionar
es normal que podamos hacer lo que
queramos con nuestro cuerpo
un derecho adquirido a través de duras
batallas en las calles ante los
tribunales y en la asamblea nacional el
aborto está despenalizado por la ley
francesa desde 1975
[Aplausos]
una conquista frágil que hay que
proteger a toda costa y consagrar en la
constitución francesa según el alto
consejo para la igualdad de francia-
ráfaga de esquí se pase a la
subsiguiente en lo que ha pasado en eeuu
la mayoría puede cambiar los
conservadores o los movimientos anti
abortistas podrían triunfar un día y
desafiar la ley eso me tocó salvo el
partido de izquierda francia en su misa
se ha comprometido a presentar un
proyecto de ley en este sentido al igual
que la réplica en marcha del presidente
macrón en un raro acercamiento entre
ambos partidos
queremos trabajar para que el derecho al
aborto se consagre en la constitución si
la república en marcha trabaja para ello
por supuesto que votaríamos a favor ya
que es una causa demasiado importante en
2019 la mayoría presidencial se negó por
segunda vez el derecho al aborto en la
constitución hoy la primera ministra
pide que el derecho se grabe en mármol